(cash register cha-chings)
(gentle music)
♪ There's a light ♪
♪ And it shines within the
darkness ♪
♪ Of the sands of time ♪
- The sands of time
♪ There's a fight ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ But the battle to be won
is with the man inside ♪
- The man inside
♪ No valley, no ocean ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ Can stop my devotion ♪
(horse neighing)
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ Nothing will keep me
from getting to you ♪
♪ Flying high, to the limit ♪
♪ Never wondering how I touch
the sky ♪
- Touch the sky
♪ Like a dream ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it
seems ♪
In the rhythm, I believe
(cash register cha-chings)
Is the power of wings
♪ There's a fire ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ And it burns the deepest ♪
♪ Fathoms of the seven seas ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ - [Wendell] The seven seas. ♪
♪ True desire ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ Let the music in your heart ♪
♪ Give way to the things ♪
♪ That you believe ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
- Anything you can
achieve.
♪ Flying high, to the limit ♪
♪ Never wondering how I kiss the
clouds ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it
seems ♪
♪ In the rhythm, I believe ♪
♪ Is the power of wings ♪
(cash register cha-chings)
♪ Anything is achievable ♪
♪ Don't let nobody tear you down
♪
- Sexually
♪ Just take flight, it's
believable ♪
♪ If you first learn
to stand your ground ♪
♪ Flying high, to the limit ♪
♪ Never wondering how I touch
the sky ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it
seems ♪
♪ Within the rhythms I believe ♪
♪ Is the power ♪
- Of wings.